what was the second part I don't know
anything about whiskey I'm not really
the alcohol type my cry
I hear it's disgusting and then I think
I'm gonna throw up for like an hour
afterwards this is a Jack Daniel
Tennessee sour mash sour and mash don't
sound appealing to me it's a cute design
I feel like this is a good brand I don't
know I feel like this is like a man's
drink
because people talk about a lot I have
high expectations for this one then
enough gonna get an effect that smells
like an old man like really strong
grandpa it was so horrible as an awful
aftertaste it's like really old apple
juice it went down pretty smooth though
not as bad as vodka I would take whiskey
over but good something to it Jack
Daniels that being said I can feel it
burning in my stomach
I'm glad I did it because I actually
think sometimes I would like to be drunk
you know I think if I had to do it I
would maybe do it you followed only by
ginger I don't want to peer pressure
people into trying whiskey because
that's not the sort of person I want to
be but do it I think it's better than
but you know hold a glass of water and
tell people as vodka I did
[Music]